i'm vengeance what's going on reject
nation
i'm greg alba i'm john humphrey so yes
we saw the batman trailer my god
i have seen it so many times since then
i've called
countless people just to talk with them
about this trailer as much as like
little things
i've caught while watching it we didn't
do our own shopper shop breakdown and i
haven't seen any easter egg video
it would be fun to check out screen
crushes because screen crush is a video
it's a channel because screen crush is a
channel i watch a lot on my own times i
think he's like
one of the best at doing the easter eggs
and breakdowns so if you haven't
subscribed to screen crush
do it today let's see what's in store
it's gonna be the first easter egg video
i've seen
can't wait to see what surprises are
here because this is
the trailer of the year hey
rhymes you're like the riddler
yeah yeah i am yes yeah look at you look
at this
i am like the riddler you know edward
i'm the i'm the writer yeah i'm the
brother
welcome to screen crush i'm ryan airy
the trailer for the batman just dropped
a dc
fandom after writing director matt
reeves gave a lengthy discussion about
why he loves batman
as i said batman doesn't have this sort
of the ability to have sort of super
heroic powers he just has
super heroic focus and superhero drive
and if you have time you should really
watch the whole panel it's great
it is great he looks like a magician
that's got to be penguin that has to be
calling for footage we know
this is going to be a different kind of
batman movie
that's the sound of duct tape what's
some kind of super criminal sci-fi
adhesive
duct tape because this movie takes place
in a grounded
real world so this is presumably paul
dano's riddler murdering a rich guy
later we see newspaper clippings of don
mitchell jr winning re-election so let's
assume that this is the riddler's victim
now notice in these clippings there's
also this tiny headline
that says seawall construction stalled
that could be
important matt reeves cited chinatown as
one of the major influences for this
movie
like chinatown was a key one because
chinatown
giddy's in investigating that sort of
the series of crimes that were part of
that story he discovers the depth of
corruption in los angeles now an
important subplot in that film is about
water riots and irrigation so i'm
wondering if this construction project
ties into the greater mystery and this
is just a tiny breadcrumb clue
matt reeves said this is year two for
this batman batman
evolving as a character and so is gotham
city this is still an incredibly corrupt
town
similar to what we saw in the comic book
batman year one we've seen hints of
gotham's corruption in other movies
usually a crooked cop or two
but in this movie the corruption goes
all the way to the top
then the murders begin to describe sort
of the history of gotham
in a way that only reinforces what he
knows about gotham but
it opens up a whole new world of
corruption that went much farther
later on riddler tells batman to open
his eyes meaning to see the corruption
that's choking the city
so a young jim gordon arrives at the
crime scene he's not the commissioner
but you can tell he's respected and has
a higher position in the department
this newspaper reads moroni drug bust in
the comics
this is the mobster that hardly put on
trial who splashed acid on his face
and turned him into two-face so this
could be a subtle hint that harvey dent
is somewhere in this universe
of course certainly the cops are clearly
working with the bat has to be which is
interesting
because later on in the trailer we see
the batman facing off against the police
i'm guessing the batman gets too close
to uncovering the corrupt police
commissioner
so then he declares open season on the
bat like here we see batman losing
temper at some police maybe like he's
finally fed up with this dirty cop and
later he uses a grappling hook to try to
shoot at him and you can see such a
great shot matt reeves also said that
this is
story batman is the world's greatest
detective but we haven't seen that side
of him too often in the movies the
poison only works when the components
are mixed
hairspray won't do it alone but
hairspray mixed with lipstick and
perfume
will be toxic the riddler leaves him a
green envelope that's a nice easter egg
to his uniform from the comics
the envelope contains a greeting card
with an owl which could be a reference
to the court of owls from batman
batman's entire rogues game very similar
to this movie but notice there's
a skeleton on the card maybe pointing
batman to the gang of kids with skull
makeup that he beats up later on in the
trailer
i've noticed that he's left a clue for
batman several scroll marks for him to
decipher i have actually already
decoded these you know what they say
this is your mom the batman suit looks
awesome now the bat symbol on the front
is actually made up of youtube
maybe the gun that killed thomas and
martha or is that a bomb basically right
here that he's adapted and you can see
all the little dings and bullet scars
carved into it and this of course
is former white house adviser steve
bannon playing corrupt post commissioner
bruce wayne is watching this press
conference which was actually shown in
downtown liverpool reeves said they shot
in liverpool to get a base of gothic
architecture
then they're adding more modern elements
with cg so hopefully gotham won't look
like any city that we recognize
andy circus's alfred gets a small voice
over as bruce rolls into the new batcave
you're becoming quite a celebrity
so let's talk about this new hq it's
clearly made from a pre-existing
structure
with these two long staircases and it's
probably underground as indicated by
these struts
and the ceiling supports here and since
we've seen him drive through a graveyard
i'm guessing this is an underground
mausoleum on the weighing property it's
appropriate since batman has never been
able to let go of his parents murder so
emotionally they're always with him
and he's operating underground where
they're buried so they're physically
with him as well
or it could be an abandoned train depot
that bruce wayne or his family bought
years ago
this would allow him access to the
entire city
[Music]
i love where this is just a guy
putting on a suit and beating criminals
asses you can also see his bat cycle
here
it's not like he's going to be riding
that thing around in the daytime then
there's a few shots from this funeral
probably the mayor's where a car crashes
into a church with doa
dead on arrival written on the side and
top there's a hostage with a smartphone
and a note for the batman
i'm wondering if the mystery in this
movie can be solved by the audience
like will a clever encyclopedia brown
fan be able to decipher these clues
along with the bat
later in the trailer the batman is
nearby when this guy's bomb explodes
so it's likely that everyone including
bruce wayne evacuated and then he
returned a bit later as batman
you can even see the bomb defusing robot
here then zoe kravitz's selena kyle is
breaking into a crime scene
probably the mayor's house they shot 25
percent of this movie before the world
ended so it would make sense if they
shot
all of the footage on this same set and
the batman fights are here later on
she's most likely breaking in here
because the place is abandoned and it's
easy pickings for a cat burglar
next there's a transformed colin farrell
as oswald
actually that's the clearest shot i've
seen and at this point
he doesn't even like being called the
penguin he's supervising or involved in
some sort of deal here involving
batman watches from high above now later
you can see cobble
firing at someone probably the batman
and then later after that he's in a car
chase to get away from him
so batman interrupts this deal and kicks
off a high speed chase
then we see a few flashes of this gang
of kids wearing white face makeup now
they could be a skull gang
or they could be hurt jokers this was a
street gang from batman beyond that were
inspired by the exploits of the joker
so does this mean that some form of the
joker maybe arthur fleck
has already existed in this universe
well maybe at the end of the joker he's
inspired people to wear his face
that was my joker's secret idea this
universe is joker could come out of this
street gang and take control of them
after all the joker movie took place in
1982 when bruce was about
9 10 and iphones exist in this universe
so the timing doesn't add up but
this lead guy does have stitching makeup
at the corners of his mouth implying
that he's emulating a version of the
joker like heath ledger's with a
glaswegian smile
you can even see this kid filming with
an iphone when we get this line
the hell are you supposed to be i love
that we're expecting him to say this
classic line
where are you i'm batman
[Music]
you sound like cookie monster but
instead
always watch it again
i'm vengeance now if a guy in a joker
mask did kill batman's parents
that would explain this brutality one of
them gets off a shot against batman and
he just takes it
again rookie batman in later years he
would never risk taking a shot point
blank
then we get a good look at the new
batmobile notice it has the booster
engine on the back but also
these panels that have been riveted and
welded into place
showing us that this is not slick it's a
homemade job
all i love the new logo and title notice
the bat ears on the a
as it forms and the final lines
[Music]
imply there's a shared connection here
between batman the riddler and all of
this corruption
without being an origin tale for him it
ends up being something that touches on
his origins
as it starts to describe this epic
history of corruption in gotham
that you start to understand well where
did my family sit in that
maybe the riddler has even worked out
the greatest mystery
batman's secret identity and he's about
to unveil that the wayne's murder was
part of some greater city corruption
but what did you guys think of this
trailer who do you think should play
joker in this universe let me know in
the comments below and if it's your
first time here please subscribe
for screen crush i'm ryan airy great
video
not bad great video let's talk about
there's plenty pointed out to me i gotta
point out the greeting card though
because there's something that really
stands out to me what you pointed out it
could be a reference to the court of
owls
however you did say the long halloween i
just
re-read the long halloween last week the
court of owls aren't in there
like at all i still do think the
reference to the court of owls could
definitely be
possible because there are things about
this uh
trailer i just finished the gotham show
this year and there are things about
this
trailer in particular that at times kind
of remind me of what gotham was going
for and i'm someone who actually defends
that show i think it's a
pretty damn good show i think there are
things that the show was going for
and sometimes they didn't really quite
hit it on the mark and i think
this this movie's uh going to be
attempting to cover similar terrain i
mean
crown out loud mata reeves is working on
his own gotham show essentially right
now you know
so setting up the idea of the court of
owls or at least hinting to that could
be possible
sal moroney being referenced on the
newspaper clipping that linking to
harvey dent but also to carmine falcone
because john turturro
is on imdb supposedly being cast as
carmine falcone in this movie i don't
know if it's called cohn or falcone i'm
pretty sure it's falcon
it depends on how dedicated you are to
italian and
showing that off but carmine falcone and
salmaroni
are rivals with one another i don't see
any casting about sal
moroney in here but we got carmine
falcone right now so
maybe the next movie is gonna be setting
up
you know district attorney harvey dent
and then in dark knight you know they
had
freaking joker be the creation of
two-face and then
maybe in the sequel to this one they
could have a more faithful
adaptation where the courtroom scenes
sal moroney
is the one responsible for putting the
acid on harvey dent's face
so yeah undoubtedly harvey dent has got
to at least be
referee they might even say like just
the district attorney or something like
that they might say something
subtle and this seems like it wants you
to kind of have the rogues gallery in
the back of your mind for a lot of this
and so yeah i wouldn't be at all
surprised if harvey like this is year
two of bruce wayne's
journey as batman so i wouldn't be
surprised if yeah the early stages of
the harvey dent
come up are probably you know on the
heels of this as well i would love yeah
personally to see
the classic you know take on that or at
least that sort of
long halloween take on the origin for
him and do sort of a more courtroom
like i don't know explore more of those
sides because you know we had a harvey
dent in the dark knight and not that i
want
a batman movie to be a courtroom drama
but as much as we're talking about
batman being a detective it would be
cool to see
more of how the law figures into all
this if we're gonna bring harvey dent in
at some point not that i'm expecting
that for this movie but i could see them
doing that you know and that could be a
way of making this more real and
grounded and all that but without doing
the same thing as what christopher nolan
did
well it seems like they're going for the
extra real step
and it's funny how christopher nolan
seems like he's responsible for the
realistic take on batman
it's kind of an inverse in a weird way
the dark knight is a crime thriller
that took its tone and mood from heat a
big inspiration
for the dark knight right was that
specific movie the whole reason he
borrowed that tone and mood is because
if you read
certain batman comics crime thriller
ensemble pieces
already exist in the graphic novels so
they were already
there and then a lot of people kind of
tout nolan as the one who created that
for batman sometimes there's shots here
that kind of do remind me of nolan's
version
especially with anything with yellow
lighting since i know no one loves doing
that here
i feel like they're going the extra mile
for the additional
level of realism yeah you know just
right down to as a lot of people online
especially i pointed out
uh at least i see on social media with
the with the uh eye shadow makeup
he should have that when he takes his
mask off and a lot of the time he
doesn't
it can be very conflicting because a lot
of the time you'll see
the batman close-up shots evident he has
a lot of eye shadow on
yeah but then he takes off his mask and
you're like what happened to all that
eye shadow how can we get barely
any of it
and then even right down to like
batman's boots
for example feel a lot more real
tangible this relationship between
batman and the police uh
what i'm i'm really excited for that
because we we've seen so much of like
batman working with commissioner gordon
but this seems like it's really gonna
explore how the gcpd feels about batman
that opening shot when he's walking
through and they're just looking at him
that might be the first time batman's
being allowed onto a crime scene the
riddler's calling him out so like we
need to bring batman in here
the way that's shot the way it's
captured at least in like it's slow-mo
and the looks we're getting of the
police really does feel
like we're looking at the first time
batman's allowed onto a crime scene
at least at least this one of this
caliber because it's such a big one
it seems like there's a hush in the room
or something like that or like yeah this
isn't the normal thing we
would be doing and yeah then to see
those later shots of him like in the
bullpen with a bunch of
what appear to be officers around him
getting into a tussle like i feel like
this could be a cool opportunity too to
really enhance like i feel like the
police versus batman has been
you know an idea you know in these
movies heads but this seems like you're
gonna throw us into the belly of that
too not only does batman have these
villains and these street punks to worry
about but also
the cops are like aggressively on him
yeah like the police
how they feel about gordon working with
batman and how
that's affecting the police department
when batman probably knows
you know how that there's so many of
these cops who are
so corrupt you know so many of them
are and then of course like i love the
idea of where the bat cave could be
located how that gives them access to
all the the ways of transport
like an old mausoleum or something that
connects in some way to the various
subway lines that would just
be smart that'd be super smart plus it's
perfectly fitting of a bat
yeah yeah like it's perfect and i love
the architecture and and like good
credit to them for like shooting in
london and stuff because i love the
gothic
angle that this movie seems to be
presenting as well bringing in those
more gothic elements too i think gives
it a lot of character and it enhances
just the paul that seems like it's still
being cast over bruce as a character and
that seems really fitting and comic book
in a very grounded way to have him enter
the cave through a muscle
yeah i know some people have you know
been commenting on his bruce
versus his batman but one thing i kind
of noticed while watching this because
not everybody loves the look of his kind
of
gaunt and sad bruce wayne but i actually
really
appreciated it and what clicked here was
i it really seemed like you could
separate these two and
it wouldn't be obvious at all the bruce
we're looking at could be this batman
character
yeah and i hope that that's another
thing that this movie can can nail as
well is
giving us a full-on bruce wayne that is
impactful and and has character depth
and stuff like that and we can feel
you know what's going on inside of him
just as much as we can live through the
fantasy of him
lastly uh penguin there are probably
plenty of people who who
did watch the first time and go wait was
that penguin let's face it
i think most people who watch this did
not realize that's colin farrell
i saw this trailer so many times i did
not realize i was calling for until
someone online
was putting photos of going is this
calling feral yeah
well i mean especially like in that car
bit i thought it was just a whole other
guy
like yesterday extra character because i
could have sworn they leaked some set
photos of him so looking here
the makeup on him and you know i've seen
colin farrell like in crazy makeup
before like horrible bosses but it's
like so comedic
here looks so natural he looks like he's
gonna disappear it looks like they maybe
even gave him fake teeth
it looks like they did a whole makeup
job on him to make a very realistic
version of
oswald cobblepod i'm excited for his
take on it and what this universe is
building up this specific part of the
bat universe is building up to
i really loved actually speaking of
gotham i really love the portrayal of
penguin on that
on that series and the early stages of
watching the rise of penguin
into the criminal kingpin that he became
kicking it off here
oh that's gonna be great and paul dana
was voiced too as a riddler have they
confirmed that's paul dano's voice it
has to be his voice but if it is
what a different take him because you
know you're so used to
uh like when you hear riddler voice the
idea that pops in your head
it's usually something that's not quite
joker but maybe close to
still yeah it's still crazy everything
to have
this like especially with paul dano you
know
who has a unique voice already yeah
and yeah he has a unique cadence yeah
and i mean it
makes sense to me like it's not the
obvious choice but for somebody who is
engrossed by
riddles which are these things that take
a lot of intellect and a lot of
consideration i actually
think that at least this sample and and
also who knows
the delivery might be completely
different in the movie this might be
trailer delivery
but yeah i i like getting that too
because it's not what i expected from
a riddler voice even though i think he
is prime casting you know when i think
of a classic riddler i can see him it's
another instance of like
great choice but also i hope to see this
in a way i wasn't expecting and it's
awesome to have a batman movie coming up
where i'm really excited to see
the riddler and penguin come to life you
know instead of it's like you ask who
should play the joker and i don't care
and i'm so excited that i don't care
right now
you know although the joker makeup does
raise a lot of questions
i like what he pointed out here about
the card and how the skeleton could be a
clue that links and i like the idea of
him following the breadcrumbs following
the trail to uncover the mystery and all
that
because it sounds like there's gonna be
some big twist reveal at the end
it's not just who's the murderer it
seems like there will be uh another
you know rug pool like how people have
been
seeing online a lot too people
referencing seven in this trailer which
i'm surprised i didn't catch on to
because i finally saw that movie for the
first time only like three months ago
and then so to watch this
trailer not pick up on oh yeah this does
feel like seven
yeah yeah yeah you know you got jeffrey
writes morgan freeman and then batman is
brad
yeah alfred's head is in the box
but how that had like after you find out
who the killer is and then there's still
another reveal to come yeah i feel like
this movie will have a similar type of
thing
at the end of oh didn't see that reveal
yeah it's got to be like a riddle yeah
it's got to have you
thinking that you've got it cracked
until the very end and then you realize
it i think
feeling this will not have a heroic uh
this it will not leave you with a
feeling of heroism at the end
i feel like it's gonna leave you with a
with a feeling of just how
hard all this is just how taxing this
all is to go through
this is gonna feel very bleak like by
the end you know
yeah i feel like there'll be a victory
but it'll be like but at what cost
dark victory yeah something like that
honestly yeah
all right guys well subscriber screen
crusher and done so already i
bet in the comments or people giving him
a lot of flack about the whole
same court of owls and long halloween
thing as if they're trying to like
completely discredit him
i still think that card could be a link
to court owls um i i just think he
accidentally referenced the wrong comic
all right he had a whole bunch to point
out here and he got one thing kind of
a real nerd wouldn't do that yeah real
nervous
don't make mistakes as a real nerd
subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a new youtube
video up
and uh yeah catch you guys soon more to
[Music]
come
you